ronald jones one of the key figures of
the tampa bay
offense regular season 978 rushing yards
post season
139 and most importantly
a piece of jewelry coming pretty soon to
go with the t-shirt and the hat there he
is super bowl champion ronald jones hey
ronald i've been dealing with a former
buccaneer who couldn't get to a super
bowl
with a map i've been dealing with chris
i like
i like buccaneers who win super bowl so
welcome to the program how are you man
thank you man i'm good how you doing
doing great i i see that you're here on
behalf of michelob ultra i
i had i had three during the game
how many did you have after the game
yeah i had a couple uh you know maybe
one or two but you know uh i don't know
if you saw the commercial but
you went because you're happy and you're
happy when you're winning so i think
that's what we're doing over here
down in temple how's it feel two days
removed you wake up on a tuesday morning
super bowl champion do you feel
different
yeah i mean the air's a lot clearer out
here
yeah i'm feeling great you know on top
of the world obviously so you know just
very ecstatic hey congratulations on the
year you played awesome the super bowl
everything it's awesome i i i mean yeah
i want to be fanboy for a second
i never won a super bowl tell me like
the night how did it
unfold what did we do after we left the
locker room and like how
you know give us give us a little story
of how it all went
yeah so uh you know just building up to
the week you know
uh you know it was great and things like
that and after you know
we had a party you know at the aquarium
you know popped a few uh nicolos and
things like that uh
yeah he got he got pretty wild so they
went you guys went to the aquarium huh
that's where they that's where they did
the after party
yeah we had amigos and uh ludacris came
through so you know it was great you
know
got on stage you know did his thing so
it was fun
oh man that's i'm like what time we
talking like we stayed up till
so sun was up by the time we finally
went to bed i mean i hope so
yeah it was about four three three a.m
who was the who was the life of the
party at the super bowl party who's the
who's the one guy that made it all go
i'll definitely go out you know what he
got on stage and you know started
breakdancing and things you know just in
a regular
uh jumpsuit you know outfit so
that was pretty funny how strange was it
as a guy who had been with the
buccaneers pre-2020 to have
tom brady and this influx of all these
new guys who
who really came in and helped make a
huge difference
yeah it's definitely crazy you know like
you said uh those guys coming in first
year and
having you know such a great impact you
know with no otas and things like that
uh just shows you know the true uh
determination
and uh work hands that they have with
brady
right i mean we got a hit on that just
like you know
in your assessment what what does it do
everything we talk about does everybody
you know you nervous you want to please
brady we got to work harder
he coaches like just tell us the
experience and kind of what he did for a
guy like you
who's still young in his career it
definitely provided a lot of leadership
you know in the huddle and you know off
the field
uh meeting with him you know
week-to-week
basis and him sending you know video
clips and stuff like that just to get
you prepared so
definitely doing all the things you know
great wood you know i didn't expect
anything less
going into the game of course you got to
have a little fear you lost to the
chiefs and everything but like just tell
us about the psyche of the football team
and having to play mahomes and the
kansas city chiefs in the super bowl
and kind of like what were you guys
saying to each other in the locker room
all week getting ready for the football
game yeah just the belief you know that
we could do it and we knew we could
and we weren't going to let you know
come down and you know in our house and
take it from us you know
uh it's been a long year and the guys
worked hard and
you know we prepared for this moment
lavonte david told a great story last
week about tom brady yelling at someone
who was crying in the locker room after
the nfc championship win over
the packers two-part question first was
it you
and second did he allow crying after the
super bowl in the locker room
yeah uh it was not me
but uh yeah he did allow some tears you
know uh
after the game just uh being in there
you know
that moment you know he said it was
about honor and uh
i think that's what it came down to you
know just building the legacy and you
know i'm great to
be a part of it and we're now 36 hours
removed from the game are you already
getting the text from tom brady it's
time to get back to work for number two
not yet not yet surprisingly i am
surprised i haven't gotten to yet
hey uh you know we all talk about your
offense in tampa
right and when it changed and when it
started to click and just
you know when that happened like to you
to ronald jones
when did it feel like you guys and the
offense you know okay we found our niche
this is how we're going to attack like
what point of the year what game was it
when you finally still
felt like you guys were rolling on that
side of the ball
i say after the bye week you know we
kind of you know re-established
ourselves and you know took a look at
our record
and we were like you know we want to
make a run at this thing we got to give
ourselves
the best chance you know to get in the
in the cup because you know once you're
in you know
all this is off so i think probably
after the bye weeks when we started
catching our swing
yeah you definitely did now like all i
know brady grin about that all the time
but give me give me another guy or two
who's somebody else like who's in the
locker room who are some other crazy
guys who's the loudmouth on wednesday
when you guys are all putting your pads
on getting ready to go to practice who's
getting everybody juiced up in the
locker room
and causing a ruckus yeah definitely uh
jpp and devin white you know those guys
are you know great leaders on the team
and they they make sure you know
we don't take a day off offensively as a
group too so
just keeping that pressure on you know
iron sharp is a greatness in the locker
room and i think there was
probably some people who did that on
those days
ronald take us inside the locker room
for the extended half time
you go in 21-6 up
you got a long time to talk about a long
time to think about what went on
during that that extra long intermission
yeah just more hype you know guys kept
saying 30 more minutes you know score
zero zero
things like that and that's what you
have to do against a team like that you
know with offense
uh that could score you know any minute
it just uh you know
came too far not to finish it so
yeah i remember it still gives me the
chance thinking about it
you get the ball back and it's 14 to six
and there's less than a minute in the
first half
what was the mood of the offense because
i think that's kind of an area where
you're like all right
we're happy to be up 14 to six give us
an idea of the mindset going into that
last drive that resulted in the
touchdown
yeah just had to grind hard and uh
finished you know the driving when we
started
uh i think we went in you know kicked
the field goal and
were able to go up so that was just good
you know
getting that kick pushing building the
lead with
with like super bowl champs amazing
experience
you know even with all that though do
you sit there and go
man i want to get back to the super bowl
and see what it's like when there's a
full stadium and it's not the pandemic
do you have that thought in your brain
at all
uh not yet you know i'm just soaking in
this one uh
but definitely i'd love to be back of
course uh you know a bunch of guys were
saying where's that next year
so uh that's definitely yeah that'll be
the mission again next season so uh
we're definitely going to soak this one
in for yeah
good enjoy it down there in harbor
island i know that nice weather oh i
used to live right around the corner
i want to ask about your offensive
coordinator though
byron leftwich he sometimes gets
overlooked and talk and like
talk about his attitude his coaching
style
and just how he is as a guy all together
yeah you know i love playing for former
players and things like that
so you know he's very understanding uh
he builds the office you know
the way that that's you know the best
players to succeed and things like that
got
you know great leadership qualities and
you know he's always believed in me from
the start so
i got to give a lot of credit to him as
well uh
one more thing mike i just wanted to ask
him a little bit like just on the
offensive side of the ball ronald just
as far as
you know were you shocked that you guys
kind of became a running team did you
think that would happen you know i mean
i i think a lot of us in the media
thought oh they'll get in the shotgun
and let brady dissect people
you know but did you see this running
attack play action attack coming along
early in the year
uh maybe not as early in the year uh but
definitely you know towards the playoffs
they'd always say you know you got to
run the ball you know win games and
control the clock
things like that so i think just staying
balanced you know was key
and like you said open up play action
pass and things like that so
like you said brady could be back there
in i say yeah
ronald when did you finally exhale
in the second half because we've seen
patrick mahomes do it over and over
again we saw it last year
down 10 points with seven minutes left
he finds a way to win the game by 11
points
when did you finally say you know what
we're gonna win this game
yeah i think it was uh probably one of
those last drives towards the end you
know
with the fourth i think uh defense had
just got
uh i think he had devin's interception
and then uh
i saw winfield you know give him you
know the piece and you know just said
you know the fat lady's about to sing so
so uh he's got a couple more minutes
taking home
the rest is history did you flash did
you flash deuces at anyone tyrique get a
couple from you did he get it
no he didn't get any from me but uh
yeah i definitely feel he's coming from
you know competitors out there
so uh i think that was you know it was
great
hey congratulations and all the best
this offseason got a feeling you guys
are going to be in the thick of things
again in 2021 thanks for some of your
time ronald
yes enjoy the mickeleh vultures man be
good
oh yes i will i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports